[Música]
hola hola hola
bolivia
bueno
soy ver o pérez
y soy cantante
y digo de esto en bolivia
podría ser pero no
bueno es un placer estar aquí
compartiendo con ustedes mi experiencia
y mi charla se llama la empatía como
leit motiv
ese soy yo a los 7 años
mi vida siempre ha sido siempre ha sido
cantar hasta el día de hoy
es básicamente a lo que me he dedicado y
creo que es importante que sepamos que
el arte
es el motor de las sociedades
si bien bolivia es un país en el que en
el que existe una cultura gigantesca
creo que no somos un país consumidor de
arte
por qué es tan importante el arte porque
genera empatía
y ahora les explico por qué es
importante el empate al esta soy yo a
los 7 años empecé a cantar
y nunca entendí muy bien que lo hacía
era casi como un instinto era bastante
básico era como me metieron a una
escuela de medicina que cantaba bien y
aunque sea a cantar en fiesta hacer
música y puedo decir que pasé por
absolutamente todos los géneros
musicales que se puedan imaginar pop el
jazz el funk la música electrónica y
etcétera para muchas personas eso puede
significar que yo no me defino como
artista de pronto pero para mí era
entender la historia del arte porque
porque cada género siempre te va a
explicar el compositor de una canción te
va a explicar el contexto sociocultural
del que viene del que viene un personaje
a crearte una canción
entonces por más de que sea un individuo
el que genera cierta música al momento
en el que la comparte se vuelve algo
universal
años después empecé a preguntarme por
qué seguía yo cantando jazz en bolivia
en un país en el que de pronto
escuchamos otro tipo de música
y me pasó esto
se llama sofía
y es una de las niñas que me enseñaron
que la música le llega a cualquier edad
y cualquier persona para entenderle el
mensaje que tú estás queriendo
transmitir sofía con dos años y ha
cantado las canciones de efecto
mandarina y para mí fue un
descubrimiento increíble yo no podía
entender y fue como que la respuesta al
porque yo estaba haciendo esto porque yo
cantaba era justamente porque había
niñas habían niños que me estaban
permitiendo transmitir un mensaje
y además porque tuve la suerte de
conocer gente como los de andré montaña
es un niño no vidente y con él nos
comunicamos de una manera totalmente
sonora
y al mismo tiempo tuve la suerte de
conocer a la gran matilde casazola con
quien también he podido compartir y se
darán cuenta de la diferencia de edades
no josé andrés ahora tiene catorce
matilde tiene más de setenta
y yo estoy por el medio
estoy por el bebé entonces vemos que hay
tres generaciones aquí que están siendo
vinculadas a través del arte y creo que
eso es lo que genera la empatía entonces
qué es la empatía la empatía es ponerse
en los pies del otro es sentir lo que
siente el otro
y
y es algo que genera que genera memoria
porque al mismo tiempo en el momento en
el que escuchamos una canción
cuántos de nosotros no hemos llorado
alguna vez con una canción no nos hemos
reído escuchando una canción nos ha
quedado grabado una melodía siempre
siempre siempre va a ser así porque
porque el arte lo que hace es hablarle
al sentimiento
y a la memoria no necesariamente a la
razón y es gracias a la memoria que me
viene esta esta otra palabra que es la
otra palabra de mi charla que es el
leitmotiv
el leitmotiv viene del alemán lake que
significa guía y motive es motivo
entonces es un motivo guía que se repite
y eso para mí es básicamente la empatía
es el motivo que hace que yo continúe
cantando voy viviendo cierto tipo de
empatía con la gente con diferentes
personas y voy entendiendo el porqué
hacer eso
cuando salí del colegio estaba súper
conflictuado porque la mayoría de las
personas que estaban en mi colegio
decidían irse a estudiar a france
en el colegio francés y todos se iban a
estudiar a francia entonces uno sentía
esta presión de que voy a ser yo si me
voy a ir o no voy a ir y tenía un puesto
para ir a ciencias políticas
y después de 14 años dije no quiero
saber más de este sistema francés en el
que te generan cierto tipo de
y conflictos existenciales de que si no
eres el mejor no funciona entonces dije
no voy a ir a estudiar ciencias
políticas porque si bien me gustaba
mucho siempre me gustaba mucho el arte
de las cosas yo lo que quería era hacer
música entonces decidí quedarme pero al
mismo tiempo estudiar una carrera porque
era importante era necesario y para
darles gusto a mis papás
y estudie comunicación porque me parecía
súper importante el tema de comunicar la
comunicación es bastante sencilla es un
emisor que tiene un código que es el
mensaje lo pasa un receptor el receptor
lo que hace es decodificar este mensaje
y así es exactamente lo que pasa con una
canción yo emisora les cante una canción
ustedes reciben el mensaje lo
decodificar y le vuelven a dar un
significado
cuando termine la carrera
y dije ahora qué hago de mi tesis porque
obviamente no quería hacer una cosa que
tenga que ver mucho con comunicación
porque tampoco era mi mi intención hacer
periodismo ni nada y decidí juntar las
artes que más me gustaba que eran
la música entonces mi tesis es
básicamente habla sobre las bandas
sonoras en el cine bolivia
a parte de descubrir películas
maravillosas descubrí cómo era que una
banda sonora que involucra música
diálogos y demás
realzaba la emotividad de una película
ya yo no empieza a pensar muchas cosas y
si se dan cuenta nuestra vida es casi
como una película que va viviendo
momentos diferentes en los cuales
nosotros vamos teniendo leitmotiv el
emotiva en el cine es la música es una
música que se va repitiendo para generar
y amplificar la emotividad del
sentimiento
entonces acá por ejemplo
tenemos ver
bueno en esta película en wertman lo que
pasa en toda la película es que
básicamente tenemos una batería y la
batería suena en toda toda la película
justamente realzando no sé quienes han
visto bernand
bueno es una película que habla
básicamente de un actor que en algún
momento fue famoso y que luego había
perdido toda la fama y que el tipo
estaba tratando de seguir siendo famoso
y te muestra la batería lo que hace es
mostrarte todo el tiempo esa ansiedad
esa rapidez
ese estrés que sentía no
tenemos el audio
[Música]
esta si tiene ahora este sonido
es de la ramona la ramona es la
camioneta de cuestión de efecto película
de marcos rice
cada vez que aparecía cada vez que
aparecía la ramona que es este auto
había un sonido que identificaba el auto
entonces cada vez cada vez que veías
pasar el auto sonaba exactamente la
misma manera y casi le otorgaba una
sensibilidad de personaje a la camioneta
entonces una vez más el leit motiv
generando una amplificación de la
emoción
[Música]
i
y si no siente miedo cuando escucha la
música de the psycho esta película de
alfred hitchcock yo creo que nos ha
marcado a todos igual por el hecho de
que escuchas esos primeros acordes y ya
sientes como que el miedo la atención el
terror psicológico y finalmente
e
[Música]
cuando nos escucha cuando uno escucha el
piano
cuando uno escuchó el piano de yann
tiersen con esta película lo primero que
se imagina es francia empiezas a pensar
en algo muy onírico te sientes enamorado
te sientes muy naif como como amelie no
entonces todos estos ejemplos nos
muestran como la música siempre va a ir
acompañando los momentos que hemos ido
viviendo y para esto también hay un
ejercicio que es muy lindo que se los
aconsejo que se llama la banda sonora de
mi vida
y anoten en un papelito todas las
canciones que les han aparecido así como
importantes en su vida y van a ir viendo
que cada cada edad tiene como una
pequeña banda sonora y por qué nos pasa
esto porque la música es definitivamente
un lenguaje universal
y por qué les digo que la música es un
lenguaje universal
porque muchas veces me ha pasado cantar
canciones en otro idioma y que aún así
aunque la gente no hable ese idioma se
va a sentir identificado y de pronto
pasan cosas como esta
[Música]
qué canción era
tenemos fondos y para él y para robar
habíamos y me di de moda de moto pero la
gran edith piaf con la vía ojos nos ha
enseñado lo que es el amor
básicamente entonces muchas personas no
entienden qué significa la letra de la
canción pero saben que es una canción
muy muy muy amorosa y como que habla de
amor por ejemplo qué pasa cuando suena
esto
a relacionándolo con
esto digamos puede ser una cumbia no
esto es una samba
heim a calella oso estaría prófuga hasta
ser amasado de un día de sol alegría
dijo hoy la que coja más síntomas a esta
casa y una mínima que vi qué pasa y todo
esto está en nuestro bagaje cultural
musical todos hemos escuchado alguna vez
la chica de ipanema y nos imaginamos a
tomar bien en la playa tomando agua de
coco viendo pasar a esta mujer
completamente hermosa y etcétera no
entonces toda la música siempre va a
tener una imagen y es casi como la vida
misma nosotros tenemos imágenes de
nuestra vida y la relacionamos a la
música esta otra por ejemplo
ah
tú
y al escuchar cantando quién era
exactamente louis armstrong tenemos
nosotros
toda esa memoria de la cual no estamos
conscientes pero está ahí porque porque
una vez más lo que hace el arte es no ir
a la razón es ir directamente al
sentimiento
hay una cita que me parece súper
importante
que es de nikola tesla el inventor de la
electricidad que dice que si quiere
descubrir los secretos del universo
tienes que pensar en términos de energía
frecuencia y vibración yo traduzco esto
como energía para mí es pasión es el
sentimiento
la frecuencia vendría a ser la
repetición que es lo que les comentaba
leit motiv y la vibración es la música
entonces si quieren entender los
secretos del universo tienen que pensar
en pasión en repetición y en música
todas estas cosas les van a ir generando
empatía
por qué es tan importante la empatía
porque creen que están en el empate
cuando yo siento lo que otra persona
está sintiendo ya sea a través de la
música o ya sea a través de la pintura o
de un libro etcétera
vamos a poder reflejar nos en la otra
persona
y si tú piensas o sientes o has llegado
a sentir lo mismo que yo he llegado a
sentir vamos a crear una mejor comunidad
porque nos vamos a entender y es por eso
que el arte lo que hace es generar
empatía y la empatía genera respeto y el
respeto es la base de toda sociedad
por ende en 6 en a no discriminar a
través del arte no hay discriminación y
tengo 12 esto
cómo hacer las orquestas las orquestas
estamos bien las orquestas juveniles de
venezuela que las creó el padre abreu
justamente para reinsertar de alguna
manera a los jóvenes de escasos recursos
a la sociedad a través de la música y ha
sido increíble el resultado de esto
porque ha reducido los índices de
violencia a niveles impresionantes
al crearles una nueva motivación a los
niños estás generando ese tipo de
empatía no y es redireccionar
redireccionar toda la creatividad y por
otro lado ahora justamente hay un
programa en santa cruz
de poesía para las mujeres en la cárcel
de palmasola
es importante que aprendamos hemos
escuchado todas estas charlas y creo que
todos hemos sentido en algún punto
cierta empatía como sentir este tema del
suicidio ponerse en los pies de una
persona que ha pensado que ha decidido
hacer lo que ha decidido no hacerlo yo
creo que es importante es importante
aprender a tener esta empatía
estas mujeres que hacen poesía buscan
justamente que la sociedad las entienda
que las entienda como no culpables y eso
a través de que de la honestidad de la
palabra
y por qué es tan importante que el arte
sea honesto porque si no hablas de tu
realidad no vas a lograr que la otra
persona entienda quién eres tú
y para eso también tengo un ejemplo
herbie hancock que es un pianista de
fechas
fue muy criticado por por su sociedad
porque básicamente él es afroamericano
hizo como su comunidad le decía tú estás
haciendo música jazz para blancos y él
decía que es hacer música para blancos
entonces le decía hablar de nuestra red
ya pero yo nunca expresó sino que he
trabajado en campos de algodón yo
entonces cuál es mi realidad decidió ir
a sentarse afuera de su casa y ver su
realidad y vio una señora que yo por ahí
y vendía sandías
y esta señora tenía un canto que ha
debido ser algo como guárdame line
y al genio de herbie hancock se le
ocurrió water management que es ahora
uno de los estándares de jazz más
tocados por todos los músicos de jazz
tenemos acá una cita de albert einstein
que dice
primero william boards los artistas para
mí son los verdaderos arquitectos del
cambio
yo creo que está sumamente explicada la
frase
un músico o un artista siempre va a ser
constructor lo importante está en crear
esta otra cita del compositor weinstein
es el arte nunca para una guerra y nunca
le dio a nadie un trabajo esa no es su
función el arte no puede cambiar los
eventos pero puede cambiar a la gente
puede afectar a la gente para que cambie
etcétera entonces una vez más
la sutileza de la importancia del arte
está en cuán abiertos y predispuestos
estemos a recibir
feinstein igual son los artistas del
mundo los que sienten y los que piensan
los que nos van a salvar qué es lo que
está pasando ahora con esta niña de 16
años grita tu nombre ella con un
discurso desde su realidad para muchas
personas puede ser una realidad muy
privilegiada para otros no pero desde su
realidad ella está dando un discurso que
está cambiando muchas mentalidades
escribir es una forma de activismo el
arte es una forma de activismo y ayuda
mucho más de lo que nos imaginamos
en youtube
y finalmente la música es como suenan
los sentimientos
yo creo que todos hemos sentido muchas
veces gracias a la música hemos sufrido
muchas veces gracias a la música hemos
vivido muchas veces gracias a la música
porque
el arte nos refleja quiénes somos
nosotros mismos
y es por eso que es importante saber
aceptar a la música entenderla como lo
que nos genera esta empatía y saber que
nos va a reflejar en el otro y el
momento en el que nos reflejemos en el
otro nos vamos a dar cuenta de que todos
somos uno y que esto es algo que se está
repitiendo todo el tiempo y es por eso
que para mí la empatía es un leit motiv
es mi motivo guía y mi voz es un
instrumento para la empatía gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]